[Music]
this episode and others like it are made
possible by the generous support of my
patrons on patreon
if you'd like to help me make more
content like this and get early access
to every new video
consider becoming a patron at
patreon.com second thought
every few years and pretty much
constantly over the last half decade or
so
the u.s enters a cataclysmic debate over
the federal minimum wage
some people think raising the wage would
destroy businesses and raise prices for
goods and services
others think it's essential to keep up
with inflation and rising housing prices
both sides firmly believe that their
position is the one supported by hard
data and evidence
but there are certain realities
surrounding this debate that are never
addressed
so in this episode i'm going to address
them hopefully by the end of this video
you'll be more informed on the minimum
wage debate but more than that
you'll have a new understanding of why
it's such a divisive issue in the first
place
let's start with some basic history once
upon a time there were no regulations
regarding how much bosses had to pay
their workers
this was back in the early 1900s and
because of this wild west of a labor
market
those who owned the factories could pay
their workers as little as they wanted
and if those workers didn't like it they
could quit and other starving americans
would gladly take their place
this worked out wonderfully for the
owner class they knew that a desperate
working population would have little
choice but to accept the tiny wages they
offered
because the alternative was abject
poverty and starvation over the years
labor laws were established to help
prevent this predatory behavior and in
1938 the fair labor standards act
established the country's first minimum
wage
a system that had already been
implemented in other developed nations
this legislation also banned the use of
exploitative child labor
which had been an incredibly lucrative
practice for early 20th century business
owners
the owner class was not happy about this
but millions of parents across the
country were relieved that they would
receive better wages and that their
children would no longer be torn to
pieces by the massive dangerous machines
the business owners forced them to crawl
into to fix
almost 30 years later in 1966 an
amendment
to the fair labor standards act raised
the federal minimum wage to a dollar
sixty per hour
and extended coverage to federal
employees and some farm workers for the
first time
this particular amendment is a critical
bit of historical evidence
because as we'll see later a recent
study made some important findings
regarding the minimum wage and
employment now let's take a look at how
the minimum wage has changed over time
six decades ago in 1960 the minimum wage
was one dollar per hour
over the following 60 years the wage
steadily rose today sitting at 7.25
cents
taken by itself this graph looks pretty
good the line goes up
here's the problem just listing dollar
amounts without historical context does
not give an accurate depiction of what
those amounts mean
let's look at the same line adjusted for
inflation that's a lot less impressive
these peaks and troughs represent each
time the minimum wage has been raised
and inflation wiping out those gains
taken as a whole we can see that
compensation for minimum wage workers is
actually
significantly lower today than it was 60
years ago
this peak here representing the 1966
amendment to the fair labor standards
act marked the high point of the us
federal minimum wage
a dollar sixty an hour in 1966 adjusted
for inflation
equates to almost 13 an hour today
nearly twice our current minimum wage
okay so we know that real compensation
for workers is lower than it was in the
past
but this is where we get to the crux of
the matter many people don't care that
it's lower because
they believe that a minimum wage should
not be a living wage that you should not
be able to support yourself on this wage
because jobs that pay that little are
meant to be beginner jobs
or things to keep retirees occupied
let's talk about that
do students and other young people make
up the bulk of minimum wage workers
yes are they typically able to rely on
their parents for housing
yes does this mean that they don't need
more money in order to simply survive
in many cases yes does that mean we
should allow their compensation to slip
so far behind the rate of inflation that
their pay has next to no value
no justifying poverty wages simply
because many minimum wage workers are
students is not a valid reason to keep
paying so little
and the minimum wage is a poverty wage
according to several studies
there's not a single county in the
entire nation where a minimum wage
earner could afford a one-bedroom
apartment
if the minimum wage had simply kept up
with inflation and productivity gain
since 1968
it would be over 24 per hour today
that's a lot of surplus labor value
that's been taken from workers and given
to their bosses
unsurprisingly the owner class is almost
uniformly opposed to raising the minimum
wage at all
but what's more disappointing is seeing
people who make 16
per hour fighting with people who make
7.25 an hour when their bosses make
thousands of dollars per hour there's a
certain mindset in america where people
believe
if i just scrimp and save enough if i
work enough overtime if i do what i'm
told
if i just work hard enough one day i'll
be the one making thousands of dollars
per hour
of course the owner class is thrilled by
this when the working class is divided
those who make twice the minimum wage
fighting against lower wage workers
earning even a single dollar more
it makes the capitalist job that much
easier remember
the people making 16 an hour are still
making less than what the minimum wage
should be if it had just kept up with
inflation and productivity
but let's set this aside for now and
address some of the common objections to
raising the minimum wage
we'll begin with the objection that
raising the minimum wage will increase
housing prices
i would start by asking those people
when was the last time you rented an
apartment
i imagine it was quite a while ago it's
understandable then that these people
are a little out of touch with the
realities of housing prices in the
rental market
the federal minimum wage has not been
raised since 2009.
between 2010 and 2020 the average
apartment rental price has increased by
40 percent
and by much more than that in some areas
let me repeat that
the price for housing has increased by
40 while the minimum wage has increased
by zero percent
so to the people saying raising the
minimum wage will increase housing
prices
that has already been happening without
raising the pay to a living wage
the minimum wage has nothing to do with
rising prices in housing or in any other
area
when people say your big mac will cost
30 if the wage goes up
they're clearly not familiar with
mcdonald's pay in denmark if you work at
a mcdonald's in denmark
your starting pay is 22 dollars per hour
you also get
six weeks of paid vacation life
insurance a year of paid maternity leave
and a pension plan
their big mac costs 27 cents more than
in america
27 cents is apparently the difference
between respecting your workers and
considering them stupid
morally deficient low-skill workers the
argument that raising the minimum wage
will increase prices on housing and
goods has no basis in reality
let's move on to probably the most
common example raising the minimum
wage will drive companies out of
business on the surface this is a valid
concern
many small businesses do operate on
razor thin margins
and an increase in employee compensation
could in theory make their business
untenable
let's return to that study i mentioned
earlier in september of 2020 a new
report was published that examined the
effects of the minimum wage increase as
part of the 1966 fair labor standards
act amendment
their findings earnings rose sharply in
all affected industries the racial
wealth gap was significantly diminished
and
most importantly for this discussion
there was no adverse effect on
employment
businesses could afford to pay their
workers more they just didn't want to
it's no stretch of the imagination to
assume that the same is true today
especially when tax breaks for
businesses and the wealthy have
increased dramatically since the 80s
coincidentally the period since which
worker compensation has stagnated
so based on historical precedent there's
no reason to assume that increasing the
minimum wage would drive companies out
of business
especially when some of the largest
employers of minimum wage workers are
hugely profitable mega corporations like
walmart and mcdonald's
but let's return to the hypothetical
that's so often used on pro-business
news outlets
the mom-and-pop family business that
simply can't afford to pay their workers
anymore
here's the thing if you cannot afford to
pay your workers a living wage
you should not be in business this is
how the free market is supposed to work
remember
your business is at the mercy of the
market if you don't make enough money to
cover your expenses
buy free market logic you should not be
in business
paying your workers is the most basic
expense of all
again the minimum wage should be over 24
per hour if you can't pay your workers a
third of that rate
that means the only reason you're in
business is because you're exploiting
people by paying them poverty wages
this is the entire basis for the
existence of the gig economy
we're so accustomed to devaluing workers
that companies like uber no longer even
classify their workers as employees
so they can get away with paying them
nothing at all but let's give small
business owners the benefit of the doubt
here
i'm going to assume that you genuinely
want to run an ethical business that
pays its workers fairly
i can understand how it would be a
challenge to raise your workers pay from
whatever you're paying them now
to 15 per hour all in one chunk wouldn't
it make more sense if instead of having
to raise the minimum wage by large
amounts every decade or so
we chose to raise the wage every year
based on inflation and other metrics
this would make the change more gradual
and manageable the workers would be paid
fairly and it wouldn't put undue stress
on you the business owner
other countries already do this instead
of leaving the minimum wage in the hands
of politicians
in countries like france and australia
economic commissions re-evaluate their
minimum wage every year
raising it to match critical economic
signifiers it's no coincidence that
countries that take this common sense
approach also have a higher minimum wage
relative to the average worker's salary
unsurprisingly the u.s ranks dead last
by this metric
okay so let's assume you're on board
with the idea that workers should at
least be paid a living wage
that inevitably leads us to the next
objection if the minimum wage goes up
they might make more money than other
low paid workers like teachers
i'm going to ask you to think about that
statement for a moment if
minimum wage workers earn more money say
15
per hour still less than what the
minimum wage should be
they might make more money than teachers
i would suggest that there's an easy
solution here
it's not to demand that the minimum wage
stays the same it's to demand that all
low paid workers get a raise
this goes back to the strange american
delusion that one day you'll be rich
no if you're a teacher a janitor if you
work a trade if you're in retail
if you sell hours of your life for a
wage you're in the same boat as minimum
wage earners
you both deserve to be paid more in 2020
the federal government spent over 720
billion dollars on the military
and that was just the base budget when
you account for other aspects of the
so-called defense budget
you get numbers that are alarmingly
close to 1 trillion
1 trillion in a single year
more money than the next 10 nations
combined spent on their militaries
there's not a country on earth that
could even come close to threatening the
us
and yet we spend all this money on
submarines and aircraft carriers and
billions of tons of bombs
we have the money to fully fund our
schools invest in new public projects
and improve the lives of all americans
our priorities are just out of alignment
with what the country actually needs
walmart made over 129 billion dollars in
profit last year
supermarket chains saw an increase of
over 39 percent in their profits during
the pandemic
while their workers whom the companies
labeled essential saw little to no
increase in pay
despite putting their lives on the line
for their employers
jeff bezos elon musk and a handful of
their billionaire friends increased
their net worth by a trillion dollars
over the same period
these people make more money in a single
hour than the average person will earn
in a lifetime
and we're squabbling over giving our
lowest paid workers an extra seven
dollars an hour
there is a sickness in america that has
been programmed into us over the last
four decades
we are conditioned to be
hyper-competitive to see earning a
living as survival of the fittest
to rely only on ourselves and see others
hardship as evidence of some moral
failing
this pull yourself up by your bootstraps
mentality has seeped into our national
consciousness and completely poisoned
our outlook on labor
like most discourse around money the
minimum wage debate boils down to the
fact that americans are so conditioned
to be entirely individualistic
that they feel personally attacked when
someone else's income inches even a cent
closer to their own
it's hard to overcome this mindset the
propaganda of suicidal self-reliance and
hyper-individualism makes it incredibly
difficult to watch other people succeed
because deep down whether we're
consciously aware of it or not
watching our fellow workers succeed
makes it feel like we have failed
at its core the minimum wage debate
isn't just about the minimum wage
it represents a sort of proxy for all
class consciousness in america
there's no easy answer here the process
of deprogramming an entire population
will be a massive undertaking
but the first step must be a renewed
understanding of class struggle
if you are a worker whether you're in
retail food service transportation
whether you're young or old from new
york or alabama
whether you're a republican or a
democrat if you sell
hours of your life for a wage you are
working class
the owner class the people who own the
massive corporations the restaurants the
car dealerships
the people who pay your wage and make
million dollar donations to corrupt
politicians
they have a vested interest in paying
you as little as possible
because that will maximize their profits
the struggle is not you versus your
fellow workers
but all workers versus the obscenely
wealthy owner class who refused to allow
america to become the country they claim
it is
a country that works for all americans
not just those at the very top
i mentioned at the beginning of this
video that this kind of content is
supported by my patrons on patreon
this kind of video while very important
is something that sponsors won't touch
to keep my channel running i rely on
sponsors adsense revenue and donations
from generous viewers
by producing content like this i lose
out on both sponsors and adsense
if you enjoy the kind of videos i'm
producing and you're able to chip in
even a dollar a month
i would greatly appreciate the support
you can find my patreon page
join our discord server and get early
access to every video at patreon.com
second thought if you enjoyed this video
consider dropping a like
if you hated it a thumbs down you can
check out my previous episodes by
clicking the links on your screen
thanks for watching and i'll see you
next week
you